Erikson's theory of psychosocial
development identifies eight stages
which a healthy individual should pass
through from birth to death at each
stage we encountered different needs ask
new questions and meet people who
influenced our behavior and learning
stage one basic trust versus mistrust as
infants we ask ourselves if we can trust
the world and we wonder if it's safe we
learned that if we can trust someone now
we can also trust others in the future
if we experience fear we develop doubt
and mistrust the key to our development
is our mother
Stage two autonomy versus shame and
doubt in our early childhood we
experience ourselves and discover our
body we ask is it okay to be me if we
are allowed to discover ourselves then
we develop self-confidence if we are not
we can develop shame and self-doubt both
parents now play a major role Stage
three initiative versus guilt in
preschool we take initiative try out new
things and learn basic principles like
how round things roll we ask is it okay
for me to do what I do if we are
encouraged we can follow our interests
if we are held back or told that what we
do is silly we can develop guilt we are
now learning from the entire family
Stage four industry versus inferiority
now we discover our own interests and
realize that we are different from
others we want to show that we can do
things right we ask if we can make it in
this world if we receive recognition
from our teachers or peers we become
industrious which is another word for
hard-working if we get too much negative
feedback we start to fill inferior and
lose motivation our neighbors and
schools now influences the most stage 5
identity versus role confusion
during adolescence we learned that we
have different social roles we are
friends students children and citizens
many experience an identity crisis if
our parents now allow us to go out and
explore we can find identity if they
push us to conform to their views we can
face role confusion and feel lost key to
our learning our peers and role models
Stage six intimacy versus isolation as
young adults we slowly understand who we
are and we start to let go of the
relationships we had built earlier in
order to fit in we ask ourselves if we
can love if we can make a long-term
commitment we are confident and happy if
we cannot form intimate relationships we
might end up feeling isolated and lonely
our friends and partners are now central
to our development stage 7 generativity
versus stagnation when we reach our 40s
we become comfortable use our leisure
time creatively and maybe begin
contributing to society
our concern is generativity if we think
that we are able to lead the next
generation into this world we are happy
if we did not resolve some conflicts
earlier we can become pessimistic and
experience stagnation people at home and
at work and now who influences the most
stage 8 ego integrity versus despair as
we grow older we tend to slow down and
begin to look back over our lives we ask
how have I done if we think we did well
we develop feelings of contentment and
integrity if not we can experience
despair and become grumpy and bitter
time to compare us with mankind Erik
Erikson was a German American
psychologist who together with his wife
Joan became known for his work on
psychosocial development he was
influenced by Sigmund and Anna Freud and
became famous for coining the phrase
identity crisis
although Erickson liked even a
bachelor's degree he served as a
professor at Harvard and Yale this video
was made for us by minute videos dot-com
who were doing everything to make
awesome videos affordable so if you want
to make your own video please check out
their website if you tell them you came
from sprouts they'll give you a 10%
discount and they'll donate $50 for our
next video which would really help our
channel if you work in a company why not
use them for internal training if you're
a teacher or school you can make your
own lessons just go to minute videos
calm and order your video for as little
as $600 thank you for watching
[Music]